our next guest is known for his
approachable cuisines
that are delicious and healthy in my
opinion and everyone else's i'm sure he
is the pioneer
really first up to the plate to make us
rethink
about the way we eat i have every single
one of his cookbooks
and his latest one is seven ways easy
ideas
for every day of the week and it's out
now please welcome
the great jamie
hey oliver hello jamie how
are you very well drew lovely lovely to
be with you today
excited to cook with you oh it's so
lovely to see you jamie
i am so excited you had me
at this dish creamy
linguine pasta with shrimp i am freaking
out
creamy pasta is my number one favorite
food on the planet it just is
and the great thing about this dish is
super quick cooking
it's really delicious it feels like
something exciting and not boring
so i hope you're going to love it today
are you ready to cook my darling girl
four and a half minutes jamie that's
insane
absolutely so all you need is to get a
pan of boiling water
um i've got a pan large pan on a kind of
medium-high heat
if we just look in front of us now drew
we got the lovely linguine we're using
fresh today which is super quick to cook
but you can use dried or any other pasta
no trouble at all we're going to use a
couple of little
curve ball ingredients in this we're
going to use a little red wine which
you know we always love a bit of red
wine right cheers and
we're gonna have a little bit of surf
and turf going on so we've got smoky
pancetta or smoky bacon so how's your
how's your knife skills drew
[Music]
so i'm gonna put the bacon in the pan we
want to get that nice and light golden
we want to get that smokiness coming out
just a little bit of olive oil in the
pan
beautiful that was going to be my next
question was do we need
any oil with the fat of the pancetta
just a little bit yeah and then we can
have shrimp time so
um look you can buy all kinds of shrimp
you can get them cooked
peeled unpeeled big small and if you
want to de-vein them it's very simple
just grab that prawn like that very
carefully run
your little knife down the back and then
remove that little vein there
and then what you've done essentially is
butterfly the prawn
or the shrimp sorry i keep saying the
wrong name no i love it
i like when you say prawn keep it coming
um we're gonna slice some garlic
couple of cloves of garlic we're just
gonna finely slice
so you can just run your knife through
that um i've got some boiling water so
this this fresh pasta only takes
a couple of minutes so we don't need to
rush that at all
if your pan is looking nice and sizzly
uh we can put a couple of your big
shrimp in the pan now like this
and then also i'm gonna just put my
knife through some of the shrimp
and chop it up a bit okay so it sticks
to the pasta really nice
and then we're going to introduce um
some red wine now normally when you cook
seafood everyone's always talking about
white wine
or rose but red wine is really good in
this dish
a little swig of nice italian
red wine into the pan and that will
sizzle up
and that will boil and then as that wine
cooks away drew
just go in with a nice heaped teaspoon
of this beautiful
mascarpone cream there you can use
single cream whipping cream
this mascarpone is delicious love
marscapone
so listen you lovely girl um rocket or
arugula as you call it in the states
um that is a herb and we're going to use
it as a herb today
so we're going to chop up roughly chop
the beautiful rocket we're going to now
in your pan
if you have a little look at mine you
can see that that cream has almost
cooked away in the wine as well
nope jamie mine looks nothing like that
just so you know i'm
really sorry no no this is a very
generous
lenient dish so don't you worry but
what's going to happen is as soon as i
take some of this linguine
that water is the secret ingredient
right that's starchy water
so that's going to bring that sauce back
and what we want to achieve is a silky
sauce
and don't be afraid to keep adding a
little bit of water
just a little bit to make it elegant and
saucy so at this stage mr cameraman
please come in
but see this look at that lovely texture
does not
look anything like yours mine looks all
one color which is
not it can't be right i promise you you
will not regret this now my
if my cameraman can get in for a
close-up that is
our beautiful dish finished plated up
a little bit of olive oil just a kiss
around the outside
hallelujah
i believe in you i feel the force you
i'm i'm gonna need it and i'm actually
i'm not gonna lie i'm turning to
lauren's pasta because it's much
better than mine and do you know what's
the most important and exciting part of
this
jamie go on girl tasting it
yay
go and go
[Music]
oh my god jamie this is incredible
i know i told you i told you
jamie let me ask you do you have a
favorite cookbook
and do you have a pick for cookbook club
yeah i do i brought it in especially for
you
because i love you thank you here
is uh there's a it's a collection of
books
there was 20 of them it's called in
bulker which means
in the mouth and there's some really old
recipes some bonkers recipes and some
classic recipes
um but they're really hard to find so
there you go that's my favorite little
cookbook
you so much i'm so excited to put it on
my wall it will be
facing out it will be loved poured
through
thank you very much for having me on the
show i love it i love cooking with you
and keep up all the great work oh thank
you jamie oliver and look i'm gonna put
this
in my mouth just like the cookbook
suggests
go to the drewberrymore show.com for the
full recipe
you